The Joe Rogan experience.
One of the things about Chappelle that's fascinating is he doesn't use any
social media. He doesn't use anything. You know, he, uh,
he consumes, right? Like, he'll go on YouTube and watch videos. He'll,
he's interested in things,
but he doesn't around with anything that has anything to do with him.
And he doesn't, he doesn't post things. He does. He's not showing you his life.
But he's got accounts. Yeah. We've got logins. He's only got one.
One. And he re recently started, it was for, uh,
Instagram to let people know that, um,
HBO max was using the Chappelle show and he wasn't getting paid for it.
Yeah. And that worked.
So they pulled it off of Netflix and they pulled it off at HBO max now.
And now that's wild. Wild. I mean.
I can do that. I mean, that to me was like, I mean, I,
I get tweets because I work on comedy central. I get tweets. Like,
I don't support you because you guys haven't paid Chappelle as if I have any
thing. Right. It's like tweet Twitter. People are attacking me.
It's like when people attack me,
cause I was playing a club that Louie had played that, you know,
a week or something, it's like, well,
that's the thing I own levity live in West Nyack, New York. Yeah. But,
um, but I was just thinking what talent, like Chappelle can just say,
pull this off. And they, and they pull it off. I love that.
He just moved to Ohio out of the whole deal.
He's been in Ohio for a long time as a Michigander. I'm like, wait,
you can have a career in showbiz. And this is,
what's fascinating about what's happening right now.
You guys can have a career in showbiz and not be in New York and LA. Yeah.
He did it on purpose because he wants to be in a place where people are normal.
He lives in a small town. He knows everybody at his grocery store.
He knows everybody at the coffee shop and he's like a normal resident.
I love it. And he's taken a number asking for sliced Turkey breast.
And some was like, that's the greatest comedy ever lived.
She lives right down the street. He lives in a farm. Yeah.
He's a fascinating character. I love him. I love him.
I love hanging out with him. He's just so fat.
Understanding. Comics always say that,
that know him and interact with him and uh, that's. That's awesome.
Yeah. No, he's great. He's always been great too. I mean,
I met him when he was 19.
So did he not then get really well paid from the Chappelle show?
You must've? No, he didn't. No, he didn't. Well,
he walked away from a big part of a big chunk of money. Right.
And that the thing that he walked away for,
I was dealing with the same people at comedy central at the time,
because that's when Stan hope and I were doing the handshake, the man show,
and it was rough. Like the,
there was a bunch of people that were not comedians and th they were not
creative, but they wanted to put all this creative input into the show,
particularly because they had the chance to put their greasy little fingers all
over it because Adam and Jimmy had left. And then they're like, okay,
now we're going to mold this into what they w w we want catch new episodes of
the Joe Rogan experience for free, only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including easily.
Seamlessly switch between video.
An audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Geri on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.